hallo mein name ist luca meiner lieben
freunde ich befinde mich im auto mit
meiner schwester und mit sandra denn wir
besuchen und meine alte schule
beziehungsweise unsere als ich besser
bin auch ich einmal mit gelben helmen
wir schauen uns jetzt auf jeden fall
wissen um unsere alten wir können leider
nicht reingehen aller kriterien sind
aber das klavier besser so verpackte
bestehen aus zwei unser hausmeister seit
sechs jahren nicht mehr zur schule wir
sind ihnen die völker tischtennisplatten
das bekommen wie sind denn die folgen
werden wir nur einen sitz hatte was nach
sie jetzt habe ich nie verstanden was
ist das denn ein bisschen gruselig aus
achtung brüder ausgelasteten gemacht
sodann wird schießt du ich hab mal aber
nicht geschafft die sache ja ich hab ein
podcast back to mars nachdenken
wenn ich rein gehen weiß noch ganz genau
wie es nicht so scheiße überdenken
das haben wir auch im podcast mal
erwähnt das ist jetzt einfach der
getränkeautomat und direkt daneben sind
die toiletten danach die dreckigen war
nach pisse dichtungen hier haben wir mal
wann schießen gemacht gewünscht aber
immer für sieg weil das konnten wir das
noch machen so stevens geführt werden
soll amerikanischen also da waren diese
schließfächer und hier an und die
chemieräume und das haben wir von nutzen
wenn sie andere schon schulfrei
vergammelte sport hat warum steht
überall gute stunde dran alter wo an den
kassen das darum für sitzbänke tauben
ist ein oberstufen café geiles ist aber
nicht
hier ist so 44 sporthalle gewesen
wir waren halt so container und dann
zwei stockwerke da haben wir halt mal
hab ich geschrieben sind einfach
komplett weg dass sie waren so
kunstmusik räume und sonne weil die so
kreativ waren auch noch wirklich
sprachen lernen
es wäre schön wenn man jetzt runter
gehen könnte und noch so tasche weil es
gab wirklich zu wenig sitzmöglichkeiten
irgendwie obwohl schon soviel
ägyptischen das hätte riesig und man
sich auch mal kunst und forderte ich
musik da ist es auch noch mal gesehen da
hinten war unser klassenraum wieder als
erwartet wurde dagegen ein kanzler dann
mit stufen badu 96 einfach so lassen
sich zum vogel ist also nur kurz um
verständnis da hinten waren diese banker
wo wir vorhin war es das werde ich euch
jetzt aber ein
jetzt könnt ihr einmal so herumgelaufen
die beleidigungen mit 95 jetzt hier noch
ein bisschen
[Musik]
dass sie war einfach unsere mensa hier
sondern hundert gästen dadurch seien
abgeworfen und scheint mit besteck aus
versehen ich habe dich gar nicht
abgeworfen das dings geworfen
da muss man sein gepäck das die wir
unser sportplatz nebenan dass man immer
mitgespielt hat was in deutschland
irgendwie nie der fall war hier unten
sieht man die männer noch mal von der
seite weicht so eine richtige cutman so
einfach könnte jetzt so gemein an wie
ich immer meine alte schule räder aber
es war wirklich alles in allem sehr
schön ist eine sehr coole zeit hier und
was ich auch besonders krass was wir
hatten
der steht denn hier alles sind das alter
peter lustig sein wagen oder das da oben
hatte ich immer mache ich mir hier ist
der zeichner einsteins grünes zimmer
[Musik]
also ich habe schon coole ideen
die umsetzung ist dann halt nur so weiß
dass irgendein von meinen damaligen
lehrern sieht es war wirklich sehr sehr
sehr sehr cool alles aber ein paar dinge
also betonklotz dahinten wahnsinn
fünftklässler haben sich die fünf
klassenräume darauf verwenden
manchmal hier bei mir machen das
schulgelände vorbei gehen vorbei dann
habe jemand braucht ja und dann habt ihr
nicht mehr auf dem schulgelände
behauptet ja ich habe auch viele raucher
lehrer immer das denn für lampen der ja
ein bisschen zu viel hightech haben die
aber auch noch eine leiche in den wald
war
da durfte ich nie mehr weil da hinten
weil mein fitnessstudio luft ist ja nie
wieder lang fahren weil hier einfach mit
leiche war in diesem waldstück sandra
das sind 100 meter das ist da müssen wir
hin
das ist das ein biotop um schwarz dahin
sind jetzt wieder die erde also
jedenfalls die ganze zeit um die augen
gehalten mitten im schulgebäude dünneres
wir uns gut verstanden hat was du willst
doch fuer ich auch ein bischen gelände
um gelaufen
naja mögliche prüfung dass sie haben sie
die fünfte räume nicht nichts süßes wird
daran hat die zeit gut er hat meine
machte noch keine buchstaben schade dass
sie von alles nicht dass wir müssen
irgendwann auch mal auf jeden fall in
die schule rein aber das geht gerade
nicht erst das den chor und zweitens
wegen ferien und ja auch hier steht so
komische teile
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich hoffe das kommt doch der kamera aber
es ist so krass stürmisch ganz kurz vor
ich zum verständnis dass der
wintergarten sind von siam jetzt
herumgelaufen und hier ist wieder und
wieder mein abitur denkmal sind jetzt
weiß ich einfach dumm gelaufen auch das
lehrerzimmer der verbotene ort
das war von unserer schultour wir waren
jetzt halt leider nicht drin weil ja
vielleicht irgendwann mal allerdings
haben wir im podcast schon extrem häufig
so wir haben ja im podcast schon extrem
häufig so alte ski stories erzielt und
wir hoffen ihr konntet jetzt ein
bisschen mehr vielleicht verstehen wie
das wohl stattgefunden hat
[Musik]